hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we're talking about the five
projects to have in your portfolio to
just give you the best
odds when you start job hunting and
really start putting yourself
out there so what are they the first
type of project
you want is a copycat project
now i'm not talking about plagiarism or
anything like that let's make that very
clear
but create something that already
exists so let's say for example tinder
but for activism and make the layout
similar and all of that because when you
show this out
it'll show employers wow she can make
something
that took a whole team to create now i'm
not saying have all the bells and
whistles and everything
but show that you understand the basic
functionalities and what would make this
app
run because you don't have a team you
don't have a full team so i'm not saying
act like you do
but show that you can
and have the potential to work on
projects like this and the best way to
do that
is with a copycat and say look you i am
applying to tinder.com well look
here here is my version of tinderbot for
activism so
i obviously am the person for the job it
really shows that
you know how to make the
top apps that are out in the world today
you
know how to bring those types of apps to
life you know those
core functionalities and what it takes
to make them run and that is very
desirable
in an employee the next app you want to
create
is some type of search engine app now
this sounds very boring but i promise
you it's not
one example could be a search engine but
for games that's actually something i
did with a team
it was a search engine for board games
that's rules for board games so you
could look up let's say
like scrabble and it would show you
all the different scrabble games how
much they were
their description and how many um
are able to play at it another example
could be a recipe app which is something
i also created
something that uses an api
data that you have to manipulate you
have to fetch for you have to use
and integrate into your app because
being able to work with apis is such a
fundamental
skill such a core skill and you want to
really exhibit that you can do that
instead of people who are maybe new to
development what you may be doing
right now is creating all that data
yourself
well there's a lot of resources for you
out there of
apis that are already available for you
for the most obscure types of apps i'll
actually add a link below
of different apis you can access about
half of the apps
i've built were from a list of these
apis so i'll link them below
and you see it doesn't have to be
something boring when people see here a
search engine they think google that
doesn't have to be it it can be
recipes it could be board games it could
be pokemon characters it could be all
these different things
that someone can search on their browser
and it pulls up all these different
pokemon
characters and all of that the next
project you want is a social
media project so this doesn't have to be
you know the next instagram or the next
you know facebook or anything
just something with the basic core
functionalities
of social media so what are those being
able to
post something either pictures or
updates or status being able to
like something of somebody else's
comment
and delete things these are also known
as
crud functionalities create read update
and delete
being able to show that you can build an
app with these functionalities which is
the same functionalities that all
of the social media apps in the world
have
is very very important and you can put
your own spin on it so again
it doesn't have to be the next instagram
the next xyz
it could be social media for i don't
even know quidditch players or something
some type of social media i don't know i
don't even i
yeah so it can be make things fun
it's so easy to just get wrapped up in
creating these things with all these
bells and whistles
just make sure you're making things fun
make things according to your interests
and things
like that the fourth type of app you
want in
your portfolio is some type of financial
app
now why do we want finance in here
because
we want our portfolio to be the most
versatile and diverse portfolio it can
be where we can
send our portfolio to bank of america
and
to you know facebook and to uber and
they
all see something that they like in
there
and so that's where the financial app
comes in it shows that you can work with
financial calculations you can work with
numbers
and so what examples of finance apps are
there we can do a personal finance
tracker something i also did
we can do a budgeter where a person
inputs their lifestyle their habits and
their optimum budget pops up for them
you can also do some type of stock
tracker some type of
stock visualization there are so many
different ways it doesn't just have to
be like oh a
finance tracker and everything there's
so many different ways to go about this
and again
have fun with it put your own spin on
things and then lastly
you need y'all y'all listen to this
you need a passion project
you want to show these people that you
are a person
with goals with dreams and passions it
humanizes
you it puts you away from just being
some other applicant number 58692
to being naya to being stacy
jeremiah you are now a person and it
creates a great connection for
interviews being able to talk
about this passion project because for
me i had a passion project that
when i started talking about it in
interviews you can see
that passion you can it was exuding out
of me out of
every sweat gland like you could see it
and so being able to really have
something that you can be
proud of and it makes learning new
technologies and frameworks and
features easier because you're
passionate about it
so make sure that in the midst of all of
this you're not forgetting about your
own
passion projects now youtube tells me
that 70
of you aren't even subscribed and yet
you're enjoying my videos please be a
part
of the community i love seeing this
community grow and please let me know
what you think about this video add a
like add a comment and follow me on
instagram
at the black female engineer so i'll see
y'all later